but it's very fair to for instance in
the beginning have a conversation with
your project lead where you very clearly
State what is important to you and of
course it's important to be a realistic
so likely if you work for an MVP
consulting firm like McKenzie BCG orbane
if you take this project lead that you
just expect that every evening you are
done with work at 8 pm I mean this is
just completely not realistic right so
this will not work but what will work is
that maybe you took this project need
that it's important to you that at least
one evening during the week then at
least a bit earlier at eight or nine PM
or so you have this evening to yourself
or maybe you state that it's very
important to you that every lunchtime
you get a warm meal because maybe this
is really what matters to you you feel
like if you don't have proper lunch
every day then you struggle to really do
your job well